- C'est correct comme ça.
- Le langage non genré :
voilà ce que met de l'avant
le gouvernement fédéral
dans son nouveau guide
sur l'écriture incriture incrit.
Il s'agit d'un outil pour la
fonction publique, et non d'un
guide rigide ou de règlements
à suivre obligatoirement.
LE SAMSON, linguiste-
conseil, Bureau de la traduction
- Au final, c'est les personnes
qui utilisent les outils qui
vont choisir les options parmi
l'éventail qui leur est proposé.
- Des pronoms comme "iel"
sont suggérés pour remplacer
soit le "il" ou le "elle".
Le gouvernement recommandeaussis
non genrés, par exemple
le mot "parlementaire"
au lieu de "député" qui,
lui, peut prendre un "e"
ou non à la fin, selon le genre.
- C'est des efforts qui valent
la peine d'être faits.
- Que la diversité de genre
soit partie intégrante
de la langue française,
c'est logique, selon
cette intervenante.
C'est une question d'inclusivité
et d'ouverture d'esprit.
Elle aimerait d'ailleurs
que les lignes directrices
deviennent éventuellement
obligatoires.
STÉPHANIE MEUNIER, intervenante
et coordonnatrice, Jeunesse Idem
- D'avoir une ressource comme
ça qui vient d'une autorité,
t'sais, au fédéral, je pense
que ça va permettre à beaucoup
d'être adressés comme
ils se doivent.
- La thèse de doctorat
de Nikitde Nikitde Nikitde Nikie
sur la place de l'écriture
inclusive dans les médias.
Elle aimerait d'ailleurs que
les suggestions ne se limitent
pas qu'à la fonction publique,
qu'elles soient étendues
à la population en général.
NIKITA KAMBLÉ-BAGAL, doctorante,
Université d'Ottawa
- On a intégré tellement
de nouveaux mots dans la lan
française et je ne vois pas
pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas intégrer ces nouvelles
techniques aussi. Selon moi,
c'est la même chose.
- Ces nouvelles li
directrices sont toutefois
loin de faire l'unanimité.
MARIE-ANDRÉE LAMONTAGNE,
écrivaine et journaliste
- Je ne vois pas pourquoi
il faudre à l'ensemble
de la population des règles qui
ne concernent qu'une minorité.
- Cette écrivaine estime
d'ailleurs que l'application
concrète des directives
réel défi.
- Il faut veiller à ce que
la langue ne soit pas du coup...
Comment dire? Perde sa saveur,
qu'elle ne soit pas complètement
aseptisée par ce langagequi int,
trop souvent, entre le message
et ceux qui le reçoivent.
- Il existait déjà des lignes
directrices sur le
inclusif en anglais.
Plusieurs demandes avaient été
formuléeun telun telun telun tel
document de référence
en français soit élaboré.
Le Bureaaduction
compte offrir des séances
d'information pour aider
les fonctionnaires
à se familiariser avec
les nouvelles recommandations.
Ici Rebecca Kwan,
Radio-Canada, Ott